morning my world it is our Met Gala
extravaganza we are joined by a dear
friend and fellow fashion entrepreneur
just like us and fashion expert and
fashion expert John target I always feel
like I want to call you John Lowe spike
owns but that's your Instagram name
everyone should follow him premium
content Premium John the creative
director and founder of Baja East so
he's just kind of heared like to give
this whole thing some levity because
like we could talk as much as we want
about fashion but like my entire outfit
is from ASOS so like what do we know
what about we have an expert so he can
dignify out of use so instead of our
usual Fast Five we are spending our
entire episode to breaking down the Met
Gala because there was so much that
needs to be said and so much that has to
be done and I just I don't think I could
live with myself about a decade dedicate
an entire episode of the toast to my
column and really nothing else happened
last night because all the celebrities
read the Met Gala I know there was like
no traffic in the city last night did
you experience that as well no traffic
no traffic if anything anything because
everyone's uptown you would think it's
the opposite though yeah every security
no everyone was like I'm sure the Upper
East Side was like jammed but you know I
was down to meat packing being cool gal
I was actually with John and like you
know it was not a problem for me
that's wonderful before we get into the
Macao we have a few housekeeping updates
as we told you we were embracing our
inner bloggers and saying me at a
special project which we do but like
we're just being annoying about it well
we wanted to wait until we could tell
you all at the same time so that not
some people knew another didn't
basically the big news is that we
officially are doing a live show in
Nashville the morning tow slide the same
way you kiss EMA fest so we were growing
anyway and we were just like we met as
well deliver a premium content while
we're on the road and we know a lot of
toasters live in Nashville are gonna be
in Nashville for CMA fest so one o'clock
today we will announce and give you a
link as to where the show is where you
can get tickets but just like get
excited and start booking your trips 1
p.m. Eastern Time yeah
tickets go live the morning toast in
Nashville I'm so [ __ ] excited I'm so
[ __ ] excited like and it turns out
we're gonna have to end up being a
national for a week
oh how terrible like you don't
understand like I'm never coming home no
don't you love Nashville I should a
dream I was in Nashville last night now
that I think about it hearing about
other couple stream is so uninteresting
yeah but that's not a terrible team okay
I'm really like like excited to jump
into the Mecca extravaganza because I
watch Fashion Police and like I watched
a taker like no side humble downhill
and I'm just really excited cuz like
this is gonna be the Fashion Police
except more unfiltered look we're not
beholden to nbc/universal we could say
whatever we want
and it's just gonna be epic and we're
joined by like someone who actually is
smart so like if we're both like so
we're very well-rounded yeah we're very
well well well rounded at the round
table row welded well we round tabled
okay okay we have a ton of pictures for
you guys in no particular order at the
end of our segment we will go through
who our best and worst are and feel free
in the comments to give some suggestions
as who you think was best and work
stressed even I already have my where
stress like picked out like the second I
saw her like I knew it
no no no wait I mean she's definitely up
there okay I mean aha wait oh okay
first we have Bella Hadid in chrome
hearts looking Maleficent chic looking
Maleficent chic that leather is working
for me I mean she looks great there's
nothing there's nothing wrong with this
no but she has been sporting a new face
like around town and it looks really
good and John was just explaining to us
chrome hearts official because like I
was under the impression it was like an
Instagram brand but it's not know chrome
hearts is huge Chrome Hearts has the
most amazing store in the West Village
in Tokyo and every single thing is super
well crafted like I can't tell if that's
a chain in her hair and it goes down
into her train in the back oh wow yeah
like that the back was really cool yeah
from hearts a second it is brilliantly
made stuff and it's really cool and has
that whole rocker edge yeah looks good
she doesn't look like she's definitely
not my best dress no she looks great
she's in theme her new face is looking
better than it has its heavenly like
setting you know something happened with
her face where like her lips and nose
and like mustache area like was altered
no where is just everything was pulled
up it's like she didn't have a facelift
because she's 20 but no but she had it's
just because her hair is tight no but
like recently that's very naive of you
John give will give you about an hour
until ok you're crossing over to the
other side noob I'm here for this and I
like this she's in theme get me chick I
think she looks cool edgy and like with
the hair and tying it all and I think
she looks pretty badass I think she
looks good yeah I'm gonna give it a 7
out of 10
she's very Bella Hadid yes also I like
that everyone was pretty much in theme
for the most part I want to get to
something because the theme was like
easier than it has been in past explain
to me yeah what is comme des Garcons
look what is that as a theme that was
last year's me well it's that was most
about Rekha Kubas work and so Rea who
started comb
okay and is influential in building many
many brands in a party she is a force
both on the art side on just I mean
she's a fashion legend she was regard
yeah you were supposed to be I'm not
sure the exact connection or thread but
it was most likely about her body of
work and she does the super avant-garde
and you know she really brings Japanese
fashion super internationally okay yeah
that makes it a lot easier then come to
Garcia how to make yeah there's a crazy
body of work there do you know how they
come up with the themes like why is it
never like under the sea
yeah eighties I think it's cuz it most
relates to art that is also hanging
right so so like for example with cubism
or Japanese art like there was there's a
connection that they obviously display
in the mess under the sea display at the
mat dead me would see it these new
pictures right they should totally do
that you should do Disney yeah that's
elevated right I mean I think it's great
for a for ages four and over and I don't
think we should let this slide that John
is wearing a cross earring and theme
with last night
it is a dagger of sorts because I'm not
very religious they turned down I think
I'm an honorary Jew yeah I would say
Jagger yeah oh it's both yeah and that's
the exact part of the theme right you
want to be on but a little bit verging
on like your own identity yeah
and I'm wearing leather maybe that's
very cap very Ross from friends totally
I didn't like a priest and I'm like a
girl who just found something that fit
and put it on I'm sorry no I dress like
a straight-up priest last night like I'm
I thought Nick Jonas was the closest to
looking like even a slight priest like
but um or we didn't see like any nun was
that close to looking like priestly and
Miranda Priestly okay person second
person is Gigi Hadid okay she's in
Versace and Versace in my opinion won
the night like they dressed everyone and
like they killed it and this is the
thing like Gigi looks beautiful but like
does Gigi ever not look beautiful like
she looks fine she's fine is this in
costume I'm not getting the Catholic
side heavenly body theme yeah I mean she
has a heavenly body so yeah that's
pretty funny she just had to show up I
mean I think she looks stunning like
your leg there's I slit it's it's
beautiful and she looks very perfect
Oscar's shouldn't like take a chance you
know but she doesn't really ever Simmons
you don't have to us when you're that
beautiful too much of a chance and it's
like why don't you just try and then
then you're Katy Perry right yeah who
will talk about in a little bit right
okay but wait one more thing about Gigi
Hadid did you see the picture of her
hugging Selena Gomez yeah okay I saw it
and we'll get to Selena Gomez in a
little because I need to dedicate a
whole hour but I guess people were like
wondering if they were gonna say hi to
each other because the tea obviously is
that Bella Hadid was broken up with by
the weekend who didn't went to go date
Selena Gomez and then then weekend went
back from Selena Gomez to Bella Hadid
it's like there's a lot of treachery and
like behind the scenes Goss and they did
actually embrace one another but I think
it was more like Gigi Aidid felt bad for
it was like she saw the way that she
looked and she was like you need a hug
that's what I also people are saying
Gigi Hadid is looking like a stained
glass window in a church like that was
the day it's pretty sure I'm here for it
I could get that okay stunning and you
know again I I don't I can't fully
connect the thing but I think she looks
stunning and ya know if you have to try
that hard like if I just got the theme
like you weren't really in theme yeah I
mean I guess some people could say today
I'm in theme this is the blood of Christ
the body of Christ and then black
because I'm a priest even the body okay
next up I can talk about these two
forever Lilly Reinhardt and glows brows
came together serving just Riverdale
cuteness look at those smiles no no one
knows smiling so big on the carpet it is
the most epic thing to ever happen the
fact that they scored an invite is
beyond comprehension like no it's
amazing and like honestly finally Anna
Wintour like got it right did she watch
her every day oh do you think has she
heard of Riverdale um Riverdale has
crossed her - no no but like she's I
feel like she's always missing the mark
like she's like a little old school and
for her to embrace Riverdale like their
everything right now like they have like
each collectively a 20 million followers
like everyone's obsessed them she is
stunning her legs look unbelievable and
her dresses H&M like of course she's a
woman of the people but she's also just
like do you get paid to wear a designer
or you just go with them I mean isn't
the Met Gala payment enough i I think
some people might have ambassador
contracts or other things but no I don't
think I mean I can't speak to what that
is but but I would say somebody with an
H&M
is definitely in connection to some cash
and checks okay which it looks really
good like that's the dream cuz I'd
rather be wearing like something great
in H&M than like taking a chance and not
getting paid yeah you guys wanna maybe
like is it crucifies that yeah yeah
because I've never seen Riverdale what
am I gonna get pushed over should watch
like I think he would really like it ya
know when I see myself on it yep or he's
mid-morning toast with McHale
extravaganza path okay and he's wearing
me was that touch I might sign in a row
with Tom Graham it is turn around out
also I watched an interview with them
Vogue basically had one of their senior
editors at the top of the stairs with an
Instagram live and like a microphone and
like I don't want to be mean but like he
did such a bad job like no no the editor
like he was probably just like so
honored like at that opportunity and he
was like so awkward with like getting
talent and he interviewed them
separately and like they were so happy
to be there like he you know how Cole is
like kind of a dick how like he like
thinks he's too good for every single a
he was so honored to be there and like
he was just happy and excited and it's
just like from The Suite Life of Zack &
Cody to the Met Ball no it's like did
you ever think did he ever think he was
gonna be at the Met Ball and like on the
tails of a CW show
no no also he looks like a passenger on
the Titanic but like John he's a buyer
thought I love Tom Brown but I'm I'm a
little the crop pant thing for me like I
think he could have pushed it a bit like
so he said think about this he said he
was gonna wear short that's very Tom
Brown and then they went with like
capris instead if he had one with a
short like I would have made fun of it
what would you have said I would have to
see his legs and if they were like meaty
legs I'm so glad he did not where she
worried you he looks at really taken
away from this photo yeah to me it's a
very modern couple like they are they
look cool they're pushing a theme yeah
you want to know what their kid would
look like yeah she's gorgeous they're
just happy to be there because like you
should be happy to be there it's like
the biggest deal to get invited and now
now I'm wondering like what's the
dynamic with like
kami Mendes I can't a Catalan user
members they're all like millions of
followers they're all equally famous but
these two are a couple and maybe that's
why they got invited I don't know why
but like the rest went on by that oh
okay shady shady
if I were them I would be so happy for
my friends I wouldn't know there so no
she looked epic like how to make them at
the after-party right of course she's my
top 5 I think she looked great okay
and I just love her she I love her and
I'm happy for her and she's my top five
because like of the picture she gave us
with Cole right and also for so long I
didn't believe that they were actually
David so they're very private they've
never actually said that they're dating
there's like a few paparazzi pictures of
them but like that's it and the rumors
of them dating started because like he
gave her eyes at comic-con it's like
they date on the show so I felt they
were kind of like doing it to please the
fans so for them to come on a red carpet
together I feel like I feel justified no
I feel amazing
yeah there is a couple that came out
together on the red carpet that I love
and adore but I don't believe in it
we'll talk about it okay next up we have
Hailee Steinfeld in Prabal Gurung
how do you pronounce it I think just
like that okay probably run she is a
heavenly body just period she's the most
gorgeous girl I've ever met like I think
she's so pretty I would do anything to
look like her
and she kills it and her evolution at
the Met Gala she did this whole thing on
her Instagram she's going to Mecca
Collison she was 14 because she got
nominated for an Oscar and then she was
like she was was nominated for an Oscar
she was a pop star and then she was like
in some shitty like franchise like it's
confusing her career trajectories kgs a
friend of Taylor Swift but she always
lands herself at the Met Ball I have
dressed her a couple times
Bella wore Baja GG times yep hailey who
else all those three so far I'm missing
out on Riverdale again with were they
pleasant to work with I worked mostly
with their stylists I think all happen
but I think all of these girls are top
are cool great she's she's stunning
however she did this thing that a lot of
the girls did which is just like we're
really pretty dressed in her yeah um
fine I don't like her to take such
fashion risks yeah but I love her and
she got a stylist for her 21st birthday
and like oh she's been killing it right
yeah they styled JLo her I think it is
she like literally she went your 21st
birthday and were like let Claire
through its like latex late
extra and she's never turned back oh
that's great yeah she could turn back on
the shoes for me there's a little bit
like mad and Barbie I know she looks
like a Barbie but the shoes the shoes
don't necessarily do it for me I agree I
think that's fair I love the hair the
crown I do think she looks great she was
an edge of seventeen looking so not
different different and it's like anyone
can look like this was just like a lot
of money and Senator Islands a little
filler and that gives hope to people
yeah no she's epic I love her who's she
dating now nobody she's always rumored
to be dating um Justin Bieber and that
and that kid with the brother yeah okay
Megan Paul yeah imagine okay next up you
let's dedicate ten minutes of this one
Kim Kardashian in Versace just a moment
let's take a moment of silence for those
breasts I thought was I don't think some
people like feel the way about the Pope
like when they like cry and then they
meet him like that's why I feel about
Kim and she certainly did not disappoint
she's not like overtly like with my big
wings she's not overtly with my
headpiece overtly with my costume like
you know what she looks gorgeous she
wore a dress like that's all she's
wearing it's a dress and shoes and
there's like a little cross meanwhile
she looks the best she's the most in
thing she's wearing her heavenly body
yeah he took that part to heart and then
slapped a cross on it she's obviously
been wearing those waist trainers
because her waist must be 20 inches and
I'm honestly so happy for her cuz
obviously these pictures aren't facetune
and everyone's always accusing her face
tuning which she does but like this is
what she really looks like guys police
yeah it's liquid gold I like it yeah she
could be the new like Oscar statues yes
yes her babies are wild look at that way
yes but you know what I just have one
very small detailed thing to comment on
like she's been working out with like
this military trainer that she found on
Instagram know they're a bodybuilder and
she looks incredible but in some of the
photos her shoulders look really manly
and broad and because she's working out
with that thing like k'kaw Beauty posted
a bunch of photos like her shoulders
look like huge because she's so built
now because she's working out with a
military today she's got a scale it back
although I mean this is perfection if I
were her I would be like how do I
maintain
this for the rest of my life and if I
might have military training totally
apparently she wore like mostly k'kaw
beauty on her face I'm just not buying
it not buying it for a second no like
she's the concealed baked Brighton she
used the winner of kaykai of the glam
like what so what was called the glam
blaze was occult that's show glam glam
bot I don't know oh my god you know what
we're saying so glum star no people were
saying that the collaboration that she
did with the winner it was like
something that she was going masters it
was something that she was like gonna
release anyway and they just stopped
hitting on it because the product was so
not it was like a smudgy eyeliner wears
like he's very precise and it was like
so not what he was about but you know
what he got three and she doesn't scream
followers it's like he's gonna be fine
Oh Congrats I love her hair like this is
so ariana grande yeah it looks good on
everyone she honestly it's just I think
the jewelry everything the dress is it's
stunning and simple but it like really
takes your breath away it's been exactly
like when people show up looking like
Katy Perry who will get to like don't
you feel II think they feel stupid like
and then Kim shows up I can walk around
like you're at a party in a huge wings
yeah they give it to the door and how
did she dance I know maybe she took them
off um I'm just I love this I'm so glad
she didn't disappoint and that we don't
have to be talking [ __ ] about her no I
was like waiting for her to come this
little nervous because like she said the
bar is so high for her yeah and also a
notable appearance that was not there
was Beyonce yeah but people had said
that she wasn't going okay
why I don't know I think she took a
vacation before on the run three Oh
when does that start really soon very
soon okay she's allowed I guess yeah I
mean and at a certain point like it's
not you know you're too good for it yeah
it's good well just good to leave people
waiting for the next year a bit like
entice them excite them be a little
mysterious right yeah but so explain to
me like it's very um Anna Wintour is
like super specific about who she loves
and you have you can't just get an
invitation right look you have to be
invited by a designer also I think
though I'm not quite sure but I think
the setup is you're invited and then
you're linked with potential designers
and or some of the bigger designers or
whatever who have a table maybe
or within the whole vogue realm already
then say might also say I'm gonna dress
like this person's the face or I don't
know how it exactly works but I think it
starts with the talent okay got it
I just find it interesting like who gets
there and who doesn't do you know yeah I
mean but like who wasn't there that you
think should have been there that you
know like Drago wasn't there
oh exactly would have been a perfect
moment for her and she isn't she face of
Versace she was way but they're very
tight yeah she wasn't invited or I think
she's probably done she must be working
on something big so she could oh my god
if she goes to the other side is it
confirmed hundred-percent
oh there was a rumor but there was also
a rumor that it was Adele oh I was the
either give me two okay I booked a trip
okay next up we have Kylie and Travis
you know Alexander Wang okay
don't first of all I'm just so happy to
see them together I'm so happy to see
her like looking happy and like healthy
and glowy and like a new mom and like
she doesn't give a [ __ ] if she has a
little bit of jelly okay here's the
thing I really need this trend of small
glasses to die I thought we were on our
way out if they're not gonna die like
she really should not have worn them to
the Met Gala I'm sorry like that's so
inappropriate
second of all like these outfits I'm so
sorry look I love her more than anything
she's my queen like these outfits are
horrible they're not in theme she
doesn't even look good like if you're
gonna go completely out of theme wear
like a kilt like em rot I didn't really
wasn't a theme but looked killer like
fine I'll allow it
she's not in theme actually look good
I'm confused I don't think she looks bad
I don't know I feel like she literally
just gave birth she's like a young girl
I'm sure she's like only I don't know I
feel like maybe she's like having some
insecure insecurities and so she just
wanted to wear what she wanted to wear I
think they might be warming up the
bedroom for some S&M stuff I totally I
don't think it's bad I don't think it's
it doesn't blow me away but I don't
really get what it is in the theme and
it just it looks like maybe a little bit
of a kinky bondage couple and she was
posing so weird like I didn't actually
see what the dress looks like I agree
also but they do look good together like
I like they dressed as a couple hmm and
not two separate people together sure
that's true so for that this is like
honestly like a very hard four out of
ten for me
no I it has it's for me to seven just
because it's Kylie just because she
showed up I'll go six evaluate it's like
like just if we're going about
spectacular and people blowing us away
from me it's it's six it's it's good
it's fine anyway just by showing up yeah
and honestly I just feel like the
Kardashians have the best time at the
Met Gala like it's obvious that they're
at the cool table like where cuz they're
friends with everyone like hailey Bella
Gigi like therefore Kim is friends with
everyone Kim and cardi B were hanging
out all night like they're obviously
just like the cool table so if you're
not in with the Kardashians I bet you
have a bad time like Demi Lovato said
then when she got invited to makaula
everyone was being so mean to her like
she really fell like she want to have a
drink and she left on my 20 a meeting
Wow
yeah so I guess that explains why she
wasn't there this year yeah she also
twisted her ankle I saw her see gee
maybe that was her excuse me she really
I think she can be a lot of times and
she can really push it I I mean I think
she was a great voice and she uses her
plans yeah she does what's up so no
she's killer I love her
I saw a horrible article in BuzzFeed
that like people were complaining that
the Kardashians didn't dress up in theme
but Kim did the end they said Kylie and
Kendall didn't know but like I don't get
why that's something to complain about
like they showed up it should be enough
for everyone no like it's a little
annoying like they think they're better
than the theme yeah and like when I I've
had a costume party like three years in
a row I'm like when people don't show up
in costume like it really pisses me off
but what if it was like someone who we
were just so glad was there to begin
with fine like when I had my birthday
last year like Rachel Lindsay came were
you upset that she wasn't oh she was
like about to be the Bachelorette and
like I was just honored that she came
that's true right yeah okay that's her
okay but these are people with like
unlimited resources in a lot of ways so
it cut for me it's a bit like alright go
for it it's like a glamorous Halloween
so they're saying like yeah it was the
opportunity to like push creativity to
push yeah it's something say do you
think they had in what they wear like if
they're design designers making
something for them I would say depending
on the person I'll definitely I mean a
good designer can also or a good
designer salesperson can but we can like
push you into their direction right so
you might be like just enamored by it
and it might
not be the most like whatever but but I
think they definitely have to say
they're like okay look looks amazing
feels right shorten it lets go riskier I
think there's definitely a dialogue for
sure
yeah like Rihanna who we'll talk about
next like definitely commands a style
session like who's she wearing Maison
Margiela she is epic and like I just
love her I just love her okay let's show
this picture of Rihanna
she's a glam bought mm she is the Pope
3000 he's wearing like a mini dress
almost like an oversized coat and then
like a pope hat which I was surprised
more people like weren't like offended
by do you know what I mean everyone so
sensitive yes sir so this is Margiela
Galliano designs marsala it's for me
it's very Galliano its theatrical its
dramatic it's and it's it looks like
she's dripping in diamonds like the
whole head to toe in this real way and
her complexion like bouncing off of
these like diamonds is everything and
it's almost like oh wait no no that's
much her usual haircut I was thinking of
the song it's always like she's shiny
bright like a diamond totally she did
you see the video of her that Vogue took
yes of course um like that's everything
yeah it doesn't even matter what she's
wearing but this happens to be epic
I'm not gonna lie I didn't like it from
the back and I saw a bunch of pictures
from the back it just looks like this
big long petticoat from the side and
there are a lot of people like Blake
Lively I start from the back of person I
didn't like it and then at the front it
was like a moment but like you know the
carpet has photographers on both sides
so they're taking pictures of you on
both sides I'm like you need a
360-degree outfit and I love her down I
just didn't think this was like I saw
pictures of her where I loved it and
pictures of her where I did it don't
think this is a 360 degree outfit which
is why I'd only give it like an 8 out of
10 do you think she went without coat
after party or a hundred pain oh she
totally completely changed but inside
the party when like Madonna was
performing she totally took that jacket
off totally wait maybe even had she
usually performs and she's on the board
maybe she was just trying to enjoy her
yes I was the co-chair the co-chair yeah
a long way I'm all clergy
oh and Versace wasn't yeah oh well
Versace just killed it like every time I
saw someone that looked amazing like oh
they were angry Saachi asides further
than AI which we'll talk about in a
little bit okay next up I'm so excited
to talk about these do Haley Baldwin and
Shawn
Mendes well Brad Goreski was doing press
all day yesterday and said that there
was a surprise couple being unveiled on
the red carpet and look people were
speculating I obviously knew it was
Hailey and Sean but there is a lot of
speculation I'm like you're you're a
resident blind reader and what some of
the blind gossip says about them is that
this is more of just like a front and
that she isn't like getting a guaranteed
invite to the Met Ball and so in making
like a whole new story about her and
Sean it would guarantee her an invite
and he might need a girlfriend okay well
it works for me because I am obsessed
with the two of them there's a couple
pictures of them that are like
everywhere and they look like prom king
and queen
they look like I don't think they're a
real couple but I want to believe it so
badly he is the hottest kid alive
yeah and it's just wild he's like from
Canada I was like making videos on Joe
Weider
on vine and now he's at the Met Gala and
making songs with uh Khalid whatever
Jon's nineteen he yeah something like
that no it's so crazy to see like one of
these girls like with an age-appropriate
guy no it's just so aware that like
people you know are matched with people
they actually should be matched like it
feels like she's robbing the cradle but
they're the same John I have a really
important question gram is it the Met
Gala or the Met Ball
I think it's Met Gala okay because I'm
seeing conflicting things I'm social me
and I don't know what to call it
I'm gonna calling it the Met Gala okay
yeah sounds more like I want to be the
Met Gala I also want to be at MIT ball
yeah but I'm gonna go Matt gala okay
well they're both wearing Ralph Lauren
right or coming off a girl I forgot
which I Tommy Hilfiger and like some
American that's all I know
they're the all-american couple I just
want to say like I don't like her hair
it's like pink and shortened and a bob
and I'm her hair
honestly like she's gorgeous and this
did not do it for me look whatsoever the
look this did everything for me
especially considering she's not in
theme this looks like a prom dress
no it's heavenly body and she has pink
hair and like all those things together
if you told me that's what she was doing
I'd be like no but I love it I don't
it's very it's very prom I I'm not sold
on on the whole image together either
yeah like even like the burgundy and the
ice blue and there's like
like that when you're talking like
couples who link up and like crush the
car yeah I don't feel that way here no
they're not like looking cohesive but he
looks hot as hell they're cohesive in
the sense that like they're both like
happy yeah be there together it look
like a wedding cake topper them yes give
you the perfect wedding cake topper it's
a little cheesy but it was just the
right amount of peace but last year I
think she was my best dress she would
buy the what she bought last year would
have been perfect for this year was like
this tutu very heavenly like white
froofy and I'm just not we've taken a
couple steps backwards it's all I'm
gonna say
agreed couple steps backward on the
dress but showing off the Shawn Mendes
is oh she was a huge leap for mankind
yes
she won he I just can't get over how hot
he is and like how he's like 12 I never
thought he was hot until this picture
I've always thought he was like the
biggest Wiener and like how is he being
like accepted into into the society no
no he's really cool I mean that's very
talented that's crazy he is very loud
yeah yeah and like he's probably
talented in the bedroom as well so you
think I think the opposite he's my gun
like grew up in the suburbs okay moving
on to a mall business in the front party
in the back
similar Blake Lively situation I saw
from the back and I was like what I saw
from the front and I was like what and
then further back I'm like it's okay
honestly she like it goes to the
supermarket and looks like unreal and
I'm just not living for this as well
yeah I think she looks amazing
no this isn't a great picture that we
have I wish we had one from the back uh
but I think she looks epic John we know
who this is Amal Clooney George
Clooney's wife no no no no no no I have
my Amala George Richard Quinn do you
notice
so Richard Quinn is a is a up-and-coming
British designer and the Queen went to
his show oh and I saw her and she's not
next to Anna yeah yes you're right on
the vogue a live story that I was
watching she said she was so excited to
have somewhere someone who so early in
his career I think this is pretty killer
like especially for another person who's
not like it's not a dress it's it feels
unique it doesn't feel like done before
it feels fresh I think the prints are
beautiful III give this up they're in an
8 I'm not with it whatsoever and I also
don't totally see how it
it's the theme I think we're just doing
roses because like rosaries I don't know
like people will just like brew roses in
their hair just to like say they were a
theme and people were just relying
heavily on their heavenly bodies yeah
which by the way like fair a great thing
don't you work hard for your heavenly
body it counts
anyone who showed up it just counts I
know I'm just like not loving this and
like her and George are just like so
like political do you know any mean like
they're totally running for office and I
just like everything they do is like
calculated but they're making the right
moves they are they are and like her
wearing likes the pants like I'm here
for I feel like her career trajectory is
bizarre she's like a lawyer and then she
said I'm the board of the Met Gala and
she's like a co-chair with Rihanna how
does that work to a girl who can do it
all you marry George Clooney it's true
yeah okay next up we have ariana grande
looking heavenly like a piece of art I'm
obsessed and who was she wearing she's
wearing cherubs that's who she is she
she said that she was inspired by the
Sistine Chapel Michelangelo and she's
the wall she's wearing Vera Wang and she
nailed the wall or the ceiling
no she nailed the wall I just want to
say like it's a beautiful dress she
looks good I'm not gonna say anything
bad about it but like it was her first
Matt gala
she has the she's like this tiny like
little pop star with like so much power
in this great body like I just don't
think this trust didn't anything for her
physically I think it's heavenly she
looks like an angel from heaven and
that's what she is that's that what she
was channeling Angelics I'd love to draw
in her hair I love everything about her
I'm not into the bow the rest I like
okay I'm into it for what it is but this
is not one of my favorites yeah no it's
not bad by any means and I like how she
interpreted the theme what look at the
artistry and I said it's a beautiful
dress I like her she interpreted the
dress is beautiful the dress is
beautiful but like for a 21 year old
girl who was like ruling the world and
has like the most insane body like she
could have been a little idea this would
have been good for like maybe an older
woman like a Frances McDorman maybe
there's a good departure from like all
the sexy short [ __ ] when we were saying
like push the idea and push like I do
feel like that's a push for her yeah and
I do like how she interpreted the theme
a lot differently than everyone just
like wearing a cross or like some roses
or like a collar agreed it's different
but the dress itself is beautiful I
would have liked to have seen it on
someone else okay next up we have Ashley
Graham who did not who do not do
anything she's a problem
and she's not in theme she is not
looking good I'm sorry and I i I fight
for her I love her
mm-hmm and I think she's epic and I
think she's changing the world do you
think she could have done better he's
another one who relied on her heavenly
body but didn't the other attempts
didn't even thrown across rich like not
only she not in theme if you're not
gonna be in theme you got to kill it
dress wise and this dress doesn't do it
for me it's a little ill-fitting and I
just think she could have done better
and she has done better and I expect
more from her yeah I think she looks
stunning like face everything blegh but
the dress for me if we're talking
fashion like that's that's not fashion
to me yeah yeah it's not it's not going
that that could be another red carpet
something man but even that I'm just
like okay Sports Illustrated red carpet
totally what if crush ya bustier style
dress okay it's a little sex and she's
so stunning and I've seen her just so
flawless and average she fell short yeah
fall short and this is her first mikela
her second I'd be curious maybe in a
second I think I may be here a second -
so like there wasn't as much pressure
but like I don't know I expect a lot
from her because I really think she's
like revolutionary and she pushes then
she pushes fashion and this is just not
pushed yeah it's needs copper she by no
means look looks ugly which job no but
the dress is rather someone like look
matte and fine and take no risks or
someone who like took a risk and it just
flopped well took a risk and then just
flop so we could talk about it I say it
took her risking wins okay next up we
have Gabrielle Union another one who
looks great for the Grammys she's also
employed in lane probably did not get
the memo
no and wait I have something to say I
have a question so makeup by Mario did
Gabrielle Union and k'kaw for makeup who
do you think he did first Union and then
well how did she like stay touched up
look you probably have they could make
up a system she's okay with that for Kim
I know I've been like wouldn't you just
want your makeup artist there with you
all day not like rushing to someone else
like a more idealistic line well would
you rather have your makeup done by
Mario or someone else I don't know I
think I would go earlier just have it
done by the best of the best
and sit on it I just saw history when I
was thinking like what's his schedule is
very busy yeah okay well she is probably
like the most beautiful girl in the
world and I love her not only wish good
things for her and Dwayne Wade but like
not only is this dress ugly it's not in
theme like a hard no for me on both on
both ends and I'm sorry I love you you
changed my life and bring it on but like
this isn't doing it for me
agreed and she looks good but her skin
tone looks bomb with that color pressed
up against this like bright yellow
yes Donny I don't get I don't see how it
connects it any way to any of the theme
okay let's try and connect it ready so
it's yellow so it's bright yellow got it
so it was the subtrees and the Sun is
next to heaven there we go
oh yeah that's definitely what he was
going for yeah okay kind of like missed
the mark completely that's what I'm
saying yeah I know like the mozi did not
get the memo his best dress and Mohsen
theme was Hailee Steinfeld they're like
even she was like borderline like
Ricky's bought a head crown and she
definitely got the dress and was like
this isn't enough and sought out her own
head yes okay next up we have Katy Perry
who definitely got the memo for the
theme there's no doubt about that I
haven't explained it I just want to say
first well the wings are stupid but like
it's a costume party so I'll live and
the dress isn't ugly and the boots
aren't ugly and for some reason all
these three pieces put together on her
look terrible like by no means is this
an ugly look and it's extravagant and
she has a great body and for some reason
it is not working I don't know what it
is okay here's a couple things that I
would have done differently I would have
done no sigh high boots and just like a
about to leak
heel but then she would or like I wish
she would have done like an ethereal
white dressing gown like full angel like
just dressed up like an angel and looked
angelic I could call them dress or
something yeah we're like flowy or and
like have it just be about the wings cuz
this is all just far too much I don't
get it I mean I think when you compete
with Victoria's Secret Angels this just
doesn't it doesn't work III don't I
don't get it I can't put it together I
don't get this who did this Satyaki oh
yeah well so so they didn't really even
versus actually makes mistakes
ya know it's just like she was making us
a whole spectacle of herself there was
like a hundred articles like Katy Perry
had to walk in sideways to the Met Gala
like shut up like just be like everyone
else aware of normal dress I just I
couldn't get there in like the back of
u-haul
definitely our like you know strap-on
like aa lloween it's like a backpack she
probably put some on and off I just I
can't put my point my finger on what is
wrong with this outfit do you know what
I mean like it's a beautiful dress those
are sick boots okay there's our little
stupid it's for me like going this thing
with going this way with the wings
everything I would have gone a
completely different color like it's
also more predictable white white wings
like I would have maybe gone more like
hard and kind of goth Paulus's I'm like
I would have made it a lot more badass
also she's posing so weird and all of
the pictures like with her legs spread
and like her hands not showing like with
her toes like pigeon-toed yeah like no
no no pigeon is like this duck I think
whatever she's not stuck this is a
pigeon she's posing mad weird totally
like instant like not owning it why do I
like rich like insecure yeah I agree
that's like the worst thing you could
say about someone eyes I think they're
opposed in same person he said that
about Kylie I didn't think I looked
insecure I could just imagine that she's
all secure yes I had the word I think
secure it's just so we've got to move
past this Katy Perry hairdo like it's
been far too long on American Idol the
speak she did her old black long hair
and she looked epic like I just like I
was like finally she's returning to
normalcy and then she shows up looking
like this like a brokedown Victoria's
Secret Angel and I'm just not here for
it you know who should have been invited
and that would have been adamant or
being in tune with what's necessary and
also she's worked with the boat recently
let me think maybe she wear no but she's
been before yeah I don't know who Erika
Jayne ah totally mm-hmm that's shocking
that she wasn't there
right cuz that would have been so cool
you know she would have come in themed
oh my god she would have murdered she
would have murdered it Angele like a
series of you she's a New York Times
bestselling author and she's the number
one housewife well so that's another
thing another blind that I read is Andy
goes every year and he goes s Sarah
Jessica Parker's date every year and
apparently what they did what the blinds
say is that like he's not really invited
and they don't really want him there but
SJP is like on the board she's like
she's invited no doubt every year she
could bring whoever she wants so she
always tells Andy solid and brings her
on brings him to the gala but like no
one really wants him there and now I'm
seeing the whole his whole social media
and everything like through that lens
are like no one really wants you there
and I'm like but he looked great they
came they were both wear dolce gabbana I
don't have a picture
but she looked so stupid yeah I'm not I
don't get she was yeah I just don't get
it
and it's just a funny because she like
is like known as this like a she it girl
because of sorry and she's like not know
she needs over Stiles are on the show to
sow her and Tricia field yes she said I
was just gonna say the same thing she
should have a Pat field moment on a red
carpet thing like this Patricia fields
have it like reinvasion especially
they're trying to push another movie
right yeah like bring Pat field in and
make it like a moment to start to get
people watching again and I joined into
what's gonna happen for them to happen
shells out but yet can you imagine if
Erika Jayne got invited and like Andy
was still a plus-one that's hey by the
way like when the day that happens like
Andy's life is over like the house sides
will have surpassed me that's why she's
not invited
like maybe SJP like it's so political
like it's so political I've ever seen in
the first Monday in May no I started
talking news they always had it's so
boring but they always have it on Delta
so I watch it I'm not sure that's very
tried yeah
it's wildly uninteresting like how all
this goes down but what actually is
interesting is the seating because I
guess every designer has a seat and the
girls that they dress sit at their table
but like I was watching snapchats last
night and like Andy Cohen and SJP were
like front row and like Hailee Steinfeld
probably wrong table with a haze against
I was like they were in the back how
does it work I don't know shady okay
next up we have Kerry Washington um
terrible I'm sorry I don't think
terrible again I think she's stunning
and I guess I think she's made so many
like cool fashion choices throughout her
time and I just I'm I'm not blowing
especially with like with her hair like
the way it is I wouldn't have gone
completely covered I would have ribbon
skin somewhere like yeah like face hair
she looks gorgeous and then it's just
completely covered like yeah
this dress does nothing for her body
yeah she's a killer body and it's a
little matronly and I don't like the hem
at the end how it goes out I'm just not
loving it but her face is gorgeous
gorgeous gorgeous her makeup was on
point her stylist
totally okay next up we have a very
surprising addition to the Met Gala but
she there a skier oh I don't know I
don't think so Kris Jenner unclear this
is her first Met Gala but she's not
acting like it is I think she's wearing
bomb on or Tommy Hilfiger a Ralph Lauren
I can't Tommy Hilfiger so I got it right
she just like I'd loved following her
and social media cuz she had the best
time out of anyone like you know she
drinks and you know she parties like she
was just really honestly honored to be
there cuz her kids always go like
Chloe's never been and Courtney's never
been like they're very specific about
the Kardashians they let it's usually
Kim Kylie and Kendall and now that Chris
was there like I was just so happy for
her like she works so hard and honestly
like this dress is ugly and I don't even
care because she looks so happy
totally I'm so happy that she got there
because she works so hard making that
ten percent and this is a little more
than ten percent and I'm happy for her
this dress the top is interesting and it
kind of a diamond the bottom just it's
weird I'm so happy for her she came as
like a duster clean up like a glam
duster I'm not into the lower part yeah
I'm not into it either but the top is
pretty and she is like weird about what
she wears like in terms of her body
because like she goes to phases where
you can tell that she's like very
self-conscious and then she gets some
work done and she like goes walking in
with her arms yeah no I just think her
body's interesting for like an older
woman and I love how she embraces it
yeah yeah but here she's obviously oh
sorry she was there less she was there
last year sorry guys
but it the excitement never wears off
for Kris Jenner yeah she was just happy
to be in my and you know what I love
about Kris Jenner what she never changes
her hair and like it looks good like
Katy Perry like she's probably never
gonna change your hair but it looks bad
like Kris Jenner knows his hair what
works for her it's her signature look
and I hope she never gets extensions and
changes it agreed do you think that
Kourtney and khloé will ever be invited
I don't know it's like it's honestly
really awkward it is but I think that
they should be made in I think all the
sisters should go together with the same
designer and I think they would be no
and if they went like with balm on like
gonna be epic
uh-huh just once just once but I don't
know but Anna is very specific and I
don't think that they would have
Kourtney or Kendall and also like we've
I mean we've reached peak Kardashian so
it's not like Kourtney and Khloe are
gonna do anything
get them invited no I'm the good good
American is flying off the shelves and
that they need Khloe dojin retailer to
to show up at the Met Gala that's just
my thought I
just and I still gonna I'm gonna hold
out hope yeah okay next up we have Lily
Collins who at first glance you might
think this is weird but I'm actually
obsessed with it
who was she wearing right now honestly
she's Javon Shay obviously she's
gorgeous like she is beautiful she's
been beautiful her whole life like
what's that like I think we used to
watch her growing up and like she was
just beautiful and she grew up beautiful
and like she's gonna be beautiful Fred
and that never happened
I love her makeup here I think it's so
interesting and no one really took risks
with their makeup really and like it's a
costume party so like makeup hair is all
a part of it whereas everyone really
just let the clothing be the costume and
I just think she's gorgeous and even if
she showed up in like a dirty rag I
would think it's beautiful and I think
this is really interesting and very
priestly I feel like she always like
shows happen something interesting and
it's not always a hit but this really is
this is very creepy she's holding her
cross like she's about to go pray yes
this is hot nun I think it's super cool
I think it's it's like the right amount
of edgy she looked she looks amazing and
to me everything is thought-out to like
the like last detail is super perfect I
think I think that makes me want to go
to church yeah I go to church for that
when I when I think about Lily Collins
I'm like wow her dad is Phil call it's
like I just could never get past that
Jenny crazy is that crazy two colors do
you Tarzan and I see yeah true shiny
that still he calls his dad he sees your
two colors shining through never forget
that
she's so underrated honestly I love this
I think this is this is definitely my
face one of the best
she took inspiration from all those
Disney movie she's always in like she
was in Snow White and the Huntsman like
she probably took this from the set
totally she hired the same costume
designer she looks great and it's like
young somebody how many of these young
girls like just hover old yeah and do
old school gowns and wear it like she
looks she looks fired and different yeah
a green I'm so glad we can agree yeah
even though we're pretty much in
agreement yes except for Amal Clooney
yeah I'm not there agree disagree next
up we have Mindy Kaling um don't know
how to describe this was she wearing she
is wearing
vassilisa well you know that it's done
yeah okay okay good let's go in honestly
this is terrible like a
I fight for Mindy Kaling's she I want
her to win in everything I want her to
like be the best mom of the best career
make the most money like I fight for her
I love her and this is horrible like not
only just a dress just a not fit B is
universally considered ugly I just seen
a Z not in theme and check through on
gloves and a crown to be in theme and
like they don't match no this is a
tragedy my next question is does Anna
Wintour have to approve of all of the
looks like does she get to see what the
designers are working on did she let
this walk down her carpet I'm assuming
she approved things yeah I don't know
those in a sketch like this wouldn't
look bad it's a dress like it's not like
a risky it's giving me like Princess
Peach vibes yes like a cartoon yeah like
Princess Peach at the Met Gala and also
like wearing a crown isn't necessarily
Catholic they don't wear crowns
it doesn't feel modern it doesn't feel
fresh I don't think it takes her
anywhere
stale still not good MJ next up we have
Michelle Williams who I love wearing
such a Michelle Williams dress by
Louboutin um
I don't love it I don't see how it's
like so in theme but she looks pretty
and I don't hate the dress it's a pretty
dress she's a pretty girl with a pixie
cut but it's fine like I'm nothing bad
to say about it but I certainly have
nothing good to say about it it's not
really in theme I'm saying yeah right
okay it's pretty [ __ ] like you would
never say she looks bad or just right or
whatever but it just doesn't take me
anywhere it doesn't take my breath away
and she's so gorgeous like she could do
better and I didn't wear anything she
could really wear anything and I feel
like she's always one to like look her
best and like take risks and maybe she
was just tired that day because like
this is not good and it's like she can't
always bring it for everyone like you
know sometimes you have to let take a
back seat and like that's true the
younger girls can work out what was that
movie 360 or three that with that like
fighter Roman Fighter movie oh oh oh
yeah yeah she'd be like a hot gladiator
maybe like but I'm not there I mean it
was 300 only men well I don't know I
never saw Michelle Williams oh they were
exactly
okay next up we have J rod and a lo oh
my god winners winners this is not a
good picture of her sorry guys sorry
hello her dress has a cross on it which
is just like okay she got the theme out
of the way yes
she looks [ __ ] sick she has a bomb on
and she knows how to exaggerate what she
needs to exaggerate and that's her booty
and her hips and like I just love her
and I think she's like her her physique
is like so important like I feel like
we're moving away from that position
we're going into like the Haley Baldwin
like ariana grande like 90 pounds body
and like we need to get back to like the
Kim JLo I think we're still in the Kim
we're in the Kim physique they came what
we should we should yeah we should say
there I like it here it's a healthy body
she dances she's big strong legs like
that's what we need yeah this is a
couple that was made for the Met Gala
because they like our cross-genre
hearts and whatever she does like they
both waited individually whatever she
said no they both would have been
invited individually but never together
Oh tom brady and giselle yeah and then
also Taylor Swift in Tibet at the Met
Gala maybe that's why it's called the
Met Gala has JLo worn by Holly stores
that's like God yes they both have yeah
that is so cool that's so prestigious
how was Celine Dion she's amazing she
wore swatches that said bye Felicia yeah
it was more like art cashmere that she's
amazing yeah she's just fine
upbeat she's amazing she was at her
residency oh really
so what are your thoughts on this bomb
on look I like it I I think I think she
looks like it flatters her I think it's
something but it doesn't it doesn't take
it doesn't push anything for me yeah I
thought I slit long okay I guess there's
no question she's stunning she always
wears the same like Fela wet sequined
tight trim long-sleeve slit and I think
it goes back to kris Jenner's hair when
you know what works for you and you know
you show all the right things like
people do what they know they look good
and what they feel comfortable she'll
never end up on the worst-dressed list
and sometimes she ends up on the
best-dressed list but she's always look
looks good it's broke don't fix it
that's her motto
I love with me I'll agree okay Nicki
Minaj I have a lot of thoughts
it's Oscar de la Renta okay and I it is
knock you its sorry it's like Cruella de
Vil vibes and also like this theme in
general reminds me of her Romans revenge
and we came to wherever she went dressed
as the Pope yes yes some of that because
this is not doing it for me no look it's
so red and this is like what Katy Perry
more last year and she looked terrible
last year this is so red it's so
unflattering like I'm just not and I
don't get it do you know what I mean if
you really take a risk I need to get it
and like the shoes do not match the
dress which does not work with the Train
I like the headpiece but they always
lost for me yeah is it meant to be a
devil reference or like Oh like Satan is
it is that what it could be all these
outfits should come with an explanation
yeah like why did you buy this and what
does it mean oh it's like Nicki Minaj
wearing Oscar de la Renta channeling the
devil yeah like that in the salon with a
knife yes I agree or like that should be
somewhere for our for us to read late
yeah no it's not good I'm sorry I don't
like this and I'm like I'm rooting for
it's like I feel like she's slowly
getting kicked out of relevancy by cardi
B and like I love cardi B but like Nicki
Minaj's worked hard she really paved the
way for female rappers but this look is
just not a good way to come back and
it's two bad years in a row because last
year she went with Miss keno and I and
she was mean to Demi Lovato how did she
the one who's needed em in the other
that picture of them where they're like
a sandwich a Jeremy Scott and like they
are looking so angry and I think that's
what oh that's what she was talking
about and Demi Lovato I believe that
Nicki Minaj does not seem like the
nicest girl no and I don't know I could
see her like not being invited back yeah
I could just see it okay well I'm not
here for Nicki's look like at all
I'm not into it okay next up a very
controversial look for a girl in a very
simple outfit we have Kendall Jenner in
off-white okay I love it like I think
she looks epic I think she how many
times am I gonna say epic like it's like
come up with another adjective she looks
wonderful she's gorgeous she could wear
literally like a dirty rag and it would
be fine this is totally not in theme and
the Kardashians general irreverence for
the theme is a little disappointing but
just as a look this is gorgeous she's
wearing off-white I think she looks
amazing the thing is like she could have
taken a bigger risk because she can
really wear anything but I love it there
she said she looked beautiful especially
not at this event she's really not me I
roll with that heavenly bodies thing
like angelic clouds I don't know but I
like this I mess with it I think it's
cool when girls wear pants and make it
super super amazing I like it a lot
maybe a little bit on the bottom of the
pants I'm a little bit confused me too
but but that gives it a little extra I
like it I think that's great it's like
everyone either with like the heavenly
theme like white angelic or like the
Catholic Cross priest a appropriate and
they both work they both work yeah I
agree I also like gleam Virgil if you
don't like it cuz like she just shows up
yes she just she's really she's the
essence of a model like I feel like she
doesn't know it like she doesn't care
she doesn't really have like a
particular stuff she doesn't have like a
particular style she just shows up and
like as a hanger do you know any mean
yeah anyways I like it and I'm here for
it I'm here for it yeah okay next up we
have cardi B and mosquito
being so cute and pregnant she's
everything in there in the whole world
but I'm gonna say this is too much
yeah it's um it's a lot of breasts it's
a lot of headpiece it's a lot of
everything and I almost would have liked
it without those side pieces signpost
the poof's like it's a beautiful dress
and her physique her pregnant physique
looks awesome and I think she probably
was using those like vagina flaps to
like cover up a little bit but she is a
beautiful body I really wish she would
get rid of those drapes and just embrace
the BOD I'm s what I'm getting a bit of
that like who's that like Guadalupe like
the candles you know those candles that
you can buy all over so true it looks
like she just came out of that it's just
a lot I wish she would have toned it
down in one sense either like the boobs
the headpiece the hair kind of the dress
and help the boobs
ya know but like not that they're big
that they're literally out but like
that's it's like she's pregnant never
sure but like I just wish she would have
turned it back in like a 10 percent I
agree III would buy the candle if you're
on the panel I would buy it like I I
think
she's always smiley happy excited
they're like he's excited to be there
yeah I think she looked oh and the
choker like she looked so uncomfortable
like physically a hunger-free she's not
smiling not that she normally would but
like she's trying to not have her
headpiece fall off not choke to death by
her big-ass children break her neck I
have a nipple fall out like there's a
lot going on I think she could have
scaled it back just a tad I think I
think next year since there have been
like so many couple announcements and
like an engagement yeah somebody needs
to give birth somebody's a time and a
little bit better it's like somebody can
give birth and really make some PR out
of it well the 2 2 Chainz proposed to
his girlfriend in the thirstiest move
eyes ever so thirsty and not cute at all
like and it it's it says loser he is
Maria Menounos getting married on live
television Year's Eve special yeah it's
just not cute thank you oh so someone
commented someone who's not there who's
a little bit surprising is Olivia culpo
oh yeah considering like she's so
fashion huh oh that's a really good pair
and especially because like some new
up-and-comers were they're like yeah
like a zag yeah I wonder why I don't
know but I'm I hope she'll be there next
year yeah I would love to see what she
does it's nice for her up something to
aspire to totally cause she doesn't get
every handed to her on a silver platter
completely as she should work hard she's
and more goals so yeah there's one good
okay next up we have M Radha in
something in everything honestly
this is almost this might be a winner
for me what it is
she's a Marc Jacobs from the back it's
studying there's literally no back like
it's her butt crack and then like the
top of her neck like it's crazy she's
the most unbelievable body and she never
shied away from showing it off which I
love she's very confident it's not
really in theme but it's so gorgeous and
like drop-dead that I can move away from
the fact that it's not in theme I think
it's a beautiful dress for the Oscars I
don't like I think she could is another
one who could take a little bit more
chances and she's not like Kendall she's
not just a model I know yeah she's also
an actress and a personality and she
could have done more I would have liked
to see a little more personality but
she's not like she's not the type of
girl who's like you know bursting with
personality like she's a little boring
and this dress is a little boring and it
kind of suits her okay there's nothing
wrong lates it's beautiful she looks
beautiful she is beautiful her body is
heavenly another
and just yet fell back on a heavenly
body top I agree with the heavenly body
yeah it's like it's lit it's a tight and
then I was gonna say slit and then I
just said it's like okay everyone the
moment former calendars for 30 minutes
definitely put like a way put your ooo
on because we're talking about Selena
Gomez who was wearing coach and justice
for coach because this dress is
beautiful it's heaven lane I get that
it's a very in theme it's beautiful
it's like she's literally what she was
wearing this on in the casket and she's
going up to heaven like from the neck
down a plus
well no I'm from the neck down she gets
a seven because we are judging very
harshly today okay from the neck up I
present you Claudia O'Shea just base
like the first thing I saw was a spray
tan like yeah I'm not cute like bad oh
borderline offensive this spray tan okay
yep the makeup is just like not working
in any way it's like she didn't most
rise in the makeups really sit you don't
you have those days where the makeup
doesn't like blend into yeah it just
like sits there like too much powder so
yeah but the flash is like picking up a
flashback and so not only that not only
is her makeup bad her face looks
completely different very puffy very sad
like I don't know what's going on behind
those eyes but I see pain behind those
eyes and as you know we read the blinds
and the blinds do not say good things
about her they say she was really
struggling and I really feel bad for
because she really looked like she was
struggling like this was sad like I
really don't think she wanted to be
there at all and it was so apparent on
her face and I'd really like feel like
she's going through a really hard time
and like I don't think it's gonna end
well like for Selena Gomez like at all
and it's really sad to think about where
she was last year at the mycolic showing
up at the weekend being cute as hell to
us looking the happiest she's ever
looked and even though like what do we
know nothing I just buy this picture
versus last year's picture there's
there's been a big change but the dress
is stunning and what's her ass how nice
for her to literally have like such a
good body that even at her worst like
she still looks like the body is amazing
totally and I also blame her hair and
makeup people the hair hair is god-awful
it will take just woke up it's so bad
first of all she's wearing like yellow
glittery glittery eyeshadow which
doesn't look good on anyone except
probably Rihanna and she has a nude lip
with a spray tan which you look makes
you look like you - yeah and it's just
it's not cool I blame every whatever it
is her makeup is out to get her because
when
she's obviously like uninterested in
being there and doesn't really care so
give her a basic look give her a
flatiron like just basic like full blow
buzz knocking power Shenyang it's not
gonna win for best look like it's not
bad but taking a risk is wearing a hair
puffy afro like that and like that is
not a cute look somebody I got glimpse
of like a cherub yeah oh yeah like where
the hair is like literally as much yeah
like just kind of stuck it's I feel bad
look I actually feel bad speaking bad
about her because it's like it's not
okay it's a lot of cement down and like
yeah she's obviously going through a lot
emotionally and otherwise and like her
dress is beautiful and that's all I'm
gonna say about it because like because
I already said the worst you didn't even
say like I thought you're being very
kind
um but just like to the people who work
for her like just like do a little
better
Nolan have some like responsibility for
your client like but not even like about
her hair and makeup whatever but just
like she's professional will be like
maybe she didn't want to go don't make
her go and it would be okay I feel like
a ticket to someone else who team is
like of the mindset where like she has
to be everywhere I'm like that's
probably why she's like breaking down
like she's like tired but like you don't
have to be everywhere sometimes when you
don't go like Beyonce it's like we're
talking about Beyonce she didn't even go
yeah I saw it so many pictures of
Beyonce last year because everyone was
like where's beyoncé all the videos
everything was last year when she did
the ponytail yeah yeah I think so that
was epic that was my favorite word was
oh so we don't have a picture we forgot
to do Blake Lively but everyone said
that she was the best-dressed but I
disagree so I didn't put it on the list
yeah okay I'm a teen in charge of my own
show next up we have zendaya also in
Versace dressing like a knight in China
yep the dress is cool it's interesting
she always takes risk so I expected
nothing less I can't get behind the hair
I will never get behind first of all
half things like bigs that end up like
four inches above your eyebrow like I
will no matter how cool they come
Beyonce had them everyone had them I
will never get on board with them this
hair color is bizarre and the hair
length is bizarre so the hair altogether
I know it's a wig it's just [ __ ]
terrible so like it ruined the whole
outfit for me but if I try and like if I
cover your hand my her face with my hand
this is a beautiful dress she has an
amazing body she's tall she's elegant
she takes risks it's like
this is more I don't really get how like
being a knight in shining armor is like
well some of us a guard like the Vatican
maybe for me this is for me like when we
you guys were talking like how do people
get somewhere I think she has an A+ team
like she this is a total Joan of Arc
reference to me and I think hair down
everything I think this is like for me
it's spectacular really wow I love it
all I think for the reference and I know
I could see where they came from like as
a designer like I concept things I come
up with like for me that is a reference
that she took twisted and I think looks
incredible to reference or not reference
throw up put in the blender okay and
that is it for our rundown and now we're
gonna do best and worst so take a moment
okay I thought a lot about this okay and
we don't have a picture first like it
stopped there so I'll do someone else
well I'm sorry we have three more photos
okay
sorry guys oh my god we have another
best dress oh yeah that deserves all of
the accolades this is chadwick boseman
fabric bows made from black panther in
Versace of course and like as a man I
think it's really hard for a lot of like
the straight dudes to like Porsche
Boeing costs and Porsche and they just
wear like a cross and like they think
they won this is everything first of all
it's gorgeous
second of all he looks so handsome third
of all like it's everything like the
shoes the shoes yeah I agree it's
perfect perfect I think it looks rad
this makes I didn't see black panther
but now I want to know it's it's the
details like the little chain connecting
his little cape like this shoes from top
to bottom and the presents under the
can't even see like it's just it's
really perfect and like for a man I'm
holy disappointed like all the time by
man for example Bradley Cooper's in the
background with a toxa entails yeah it's
it's impressive best nail for sure and
he's like really starting out in his
career and this is a great way to ensure
your get invited next year a hundred
percent we will see chadwick boseman
next year at mikela we will okay then we
have I think one of my nominees for
worse dress which is shailene woodley in
a designer for should be
I also think it might be Versace so like
real Ralph Lauren he should be yeah or
ruff ruff Lipschitz should really be
upset also did Kerry Washington so he
was really into covering up beautiful
bodies yeah he was not in tune with less
necessary no from top to bottom this
just doesn't work for me that defensive
yeah like yeah it's a little bit my knee
court jester yeah it does not look great
that's a really good point it looks
cheap and then just to top it all off
not that not that it's my Florence fault
but like this hair is awful but and
she's beautiful and she I feel like she
like hates that she's beautiful because
she's always looking bad and she like
wants to not be beautiful anymore like
that's the vibe I get from her and she
also I feel like hates that she's famous
like she doesn't want to be here and you
know what we don't want to see her then
give your ticket to to like to someone
else who might want to go like hi like a
couple people sitting here
hi are you also give us Selena Gomez's
ticket too okay and lastly we have Elon
Musk and his new girlfriend
Grimes okay and she is really living up
to her name and being grimy as hell he
is so handsome and rich and funny and I
loved him like I only want good things
for him and like how are and they
innovate and how and how how did these
two even meet also Amber Heard as
they're looking and jelly look
sensational posh she's looking for hard
for her yeah but like she broke up with
him so she doesn't even need to prove
any I feel like Elon Musk doesn't know
his self-worth and like this is so
evident in the fact that he showed up
with this thing with Janis yeah he
showed up with Jonathan maybe he already
went to Mars
you know what he's seen everything and
you know what like now he just wanted to
explore a different life he does look a
little bit like Star Trek waiter took
his jacket and stuff on there there on
another planet there literally they took
a Tesla to Mars they look insane look at
some like handsome I think he looks fine
cuz he like did a priest collar like I'm
so he tried in him like also like if he
wants to date this girl fine but like to
get on a red carpet together like the
biggest like know to give her a pastiche
of going to the Macallan the
unsurmountable with Elon not
unforgettable just hang out inside yeah
get to know each other this is this is
rich a skater
yeah this is bad okay so now they love
my speech oh me too me too
oh yeah he's obviously going through
something let's let's wrap it with Best
Actress let's start with best cuz that's
like always nicer and easier and I'm
really torn but I have to go with my
basic [ __ ] answer and say Kim are the
same look and I just love her okay I
don't know if she was necessarily the
bathro Lily Collins yeah oh that's a
good or zendaya those are my two that
I'm gonna go Lily Collins because Kim is
like such an amazing actor and she is
our best dressed let's do our second
master okay fine fine Fred Fred fine
oh okay I'll go through jana because
like that's also a basic answer and she
looks wonderful I'm gonna go with do not
say Haley Baldwin no but Lillian Cole
together
Oh actually I agree I sit as a one as I
see a good unit no Kate and her
individually is up there for me and also
what would you say for best couple lily
and I'm Cole the riverdale kiss I'm
gonna go with Ilana and Grimes honestly
I'm going with Hailey and Sean because
they just like they gave me some know
that I need it I just needed like some
like Oh like you know youngness like you
know j14 yeah that's the cover of their
magazine tomorrow and I'm happy for them
yeah and for the content I'm having for
these two that they got to go and now
let's move into the worst-dressed
someone who just didn't take any risks
fell flat of the costume I'm gonna say
and I feel guilty because I absolutely
love her like I'm Gabrielle Union like
it was really bad because like not only
did she like so fall so far away from
the theme the dress wasn't even pretty
and like she's too beautiful to wear a
dress that ugly so I'm sorry I'm going
with Gabrielle Union in that yellow
proble growing a dress I'm going
shailene woodley it's just like it's so
I'm gonna second that I know it is
obvious is but just it's just like
everyone's saying like you want to go to
this thing that could be so fabulous and
you're just you didn't bring it at all
like yeah you didn't even look in the
mirror and like give yourself a pep talk
to be like I'm gonna crush this carpet
yeah you were just like no I'm just poof
sleeves like who knows no excitement
excitement no I just not good not good
yeah you guys we should do this more
often because it was literally so fun
yeah and apparently oh my god it's so
late wow this thing came along this
episode ever
okay well if you want to follow
oh my people want to know my jacket
it's from boohoo and it was 50% about
the wrong yeah it's roughly cracked like
heavenly bodies you guys make sure
you're following John Laws pinecones on
Instagram our guest for today premium
content being stirred up served up at
John Moz pine cones if you missed our
big announcement in the beginning of the
show our special announcement was that
we are doing a Nashville live show I
think it's June something we will
announce that one yet just June it's a
Wednesday before CMA fest yeah yeah do
sis make sure you're following us on
Instagram we're gonna release all the
ticket information at 1 p.m. and
hopefully you guys will be able to get
tickets I'm really excited about it this
is the morning toast we're live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on Facebook and on YouTube and we're
also available in the podcast app so
make sure like us on Facebook subscribe
to us on YouTube and leave us some
positive review about how gorgeous we
are on our podcast app we will see you
tomorrow two things our second patreon
episode came out yesterday really funny
a lot of TV moments and two people want
me to tell you that Gabrielle Union
stresses of vatican yellow in case that
changes things but is the vatican yellow
vatican yellow like is it sky blue I
don't know like a lot of it so I'll just
say chillin Woodley because everyone
else said it six new runs six your gun
says bye guys bye